good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia and i'm proud
to welcome you to this edition of our 2021
2022 foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated translational
health institute of virginia the uva brain
institute the college of arts and sciences
the school of data science and through
a grant from the national institutes
of general medical sciences this year's theme
is ethical challenges of artificial intelligence
and biomedicine where we enjoy presentations
on friday afternoons from leading thinkers
about the promise opportunities and
hurdles associated with ai applications
in the biomedical sciences selected participants
in our biomedical data science innovation lab
program will leverage these presentations as
vital material for our culminating in-person
grant project development workshop to be held here
in historic charlottesville virginia in june today
i am delighted to welcome our speaker dr yann joly
from the mcgill university in montreal canada he
is a full professor in the faculty of medical
sorry medicine department of human genetics
and cross-appointed the bioethics unit and
mcgill university where he is research director
of the center for genomics and policy he has been
at mcgills i just learned since 2009 and he serves
as the current chair of the bioethics work group
of the international human epigenome consortium
and the co-lead of the regulatory and ethics
work stream of the global alliance for genomics
and health professor joly's research interests
lie at the interface of the fields of scientific
knowledge health law and bioethics in continuing
with our theme for this year in terms of our
seminar series dr yann joly's lecture will
be entitled addressing key challenges in
genomic health and data sharing the importance of
studying large and diverse biomedical data sets
is a major advance is now widely recognized and
big data is central to the concept of learning
health care systems and applying them to ai in
the health field and following on this governments
publishers and other stakeholders are actively
encouraging the sharing of data as we will learn
professors joly's presentation today
will discuss some of the key challenges
to sharing data and highlight recent strategies
and tools developed by the international community
to address them as always we are streaming this
lecture live and for recording via youtube and
if you are watching by youtube thank you
for joining us also our specially selected
2021 2022 biomedical data science innovation
lab participants are encouraged to submit any
questions they have by the chat feature in their
zoom sessions i'll synthesize these questions
and i will ask them on your behalf during
the last 10 minutes or so in the lecture
and with that jan thank you so much we
are super excited to hear from you today
thank you for the kind introduction
professor van horn and uh thank you for
the foundation of biomedical data sciences and
for and the university of virginia for the kind
invitation to present here today so i will start
with the official disclosure as was mentioned in
the introduction i am currently the co-lead
of the global alliance for genomic and health
uh regulatory and ethics work stream and i am the
scientific director and ceo of an organization
called the genetic discrimination observatory and
uh both of these organizations will be discussed
in the presentation and some of the tools from
these organization will also be uh presented
so i think that uh it's safe to say that
our topic for today uh genomics and health
data sharing is is something that's extremely
timely uh that is uh in full spotlight
uh for everybody that is uh working in
genomic research and in other ohmic sciences
uh you've all heard about uh the new upcoming uh
data sharing policy from the nih uh they already
of course added data sharing uh policy but this is
basically reinforcing this policy expanding it and
modernizing it and it's going to impact everyone
involved in in biomedical research and beyond so i
think it's very important uh to discuss some of
the implications that that this policy and and
other similar policy will have for researchers uh
and i'm gonna take uh an international perspective
to this discussion uh but at the same time the
challenges are very similar all over the world
uh in terms of what this can how this will impact
researchers uh so with that being said let me just
change to my next slide i'm struggling a bit
with uh the slide change but that's it fixed
okay so this is the outline for the talk today uh
so we'll start by discussing how did we get there
uh how did we get to this broad data sharing
uh movement in in scientific research and in
genetics more specifically uh then we'll be
discussing about you know what is what is
different if anything about uh genetic data that
that warrants us to to discuss it in this specific
context and how can we account for that
as we're going to be uh sharing our data
then we will really start uh with the going into
the art of our topic and we'll really discuss uh
four uh different domains uh that have been
specifically uh that have caused specific
challenges to data sharing and and we'll also uh
briefly look at what could be some opportunities
and solutions to address the challenges uh
raised by these different dome domains and
and i hope after the talk we can have a fruitful
conversation and really the objective is to be
has sort of helpful and accessible in the
information i'll be conveying uh we can get
to very granular level in the questions but i'll
be staying at a mostly general level for the
presentation to cover the large uh scope that i
am trying to cover so how did we get there uh well
it's it's been a long uh trip uh it started
really this discussion about open data sharing
uh started with uh the human genome project where
really we tried we there was this competition
to get the full sequence of the human genome as
quickly as possible uh between the public and
private uh basically uh team uh of researchers
in the states and and really uh it was in in
the process of doing this uh human genome project
that we found out important collaboration and data
sharing was and that's the first time some of the
key principles on we should share data what kind
of data should be shared and and key consideration
on how to share it uh so uh this was in 1996.
uh soon again it was felt that this is working
well this data sharing uh we need to expand it
uh and and that's where we started uh thinking
about it's expanding it to different data sets
also thinking about uh different stakeholders in
data sharing because one of the you know issues
if you want researchers to share their data is
they're not going to do it by themselves they they
need help it's a complicated process to change to
share your data it can be cumbersome so it's an
ecosystem project really data sharing and other
stakeholders such as research funders such as
publishers institutions may have a responsibility
in making this data sharing possible and in
ensuring this data sharing so that was uh sort
of what the fort lauderdale was pushing towards
uh and and also uh we have to think uh
beyond just human genetics when we talk
think about data sharing and and that's been a bit
of a challenge because very soon in the process a
different regime was established for non-human
genetic material by an international convention
on biodiversity which which interestingly enough
the us is is one of the country that is not part
of this convention but a large number of
other countries are so when we talk about
international data sharing that convention is very
relevant and that convention was reinforced uh by
the nagoya protocol in 2010 on access and benefit
sharing and really the impact of that protocol
has been that it really limited data
sharing in wanting to protect uh the
the non-human genetic data of developing country
which is of course a great idea the problem
is it has really uh complexified the way
that non-human genetic data could be shared
uh and for that reason and after a few pandemics
warning in in 2011 who adopted uh pandemic
influenza preparedness framework uh to allow and
facilitate uh genetic data while the sharing of
biomedical data including genetic data in the
context of pandemic and to sort of facilitate it
uh as i mentioned it had became quite challenging
with nagoya so it was really sort of coming back
and saying well in case of pandemic
here's what needs to take precedence
uh so all of these documents by the way that i am
mentioning right now are all available and i i do
recommend that people that are interested in data
sharing consult them they're all quite helpful uh
so uh next in 2013 uh an alliance uh basically a
consortium of over 500 public and private partners
organ institutional partners called the
global alliance for genomics and health
was created really to promote uh data sharing
to develop the kind of tools that were essential
to promote data sharing and basically
they developed both bioinformatics tools
and also ethical tools to make this large-scale
data sharing possible uh and and they work across
several work streams that focus on different
specificity of data sharing uh so that uh uh
that alliance was created in 2013 uh in 2016 the
fair uh guiding principle uh for scientific data
management and stewardship uh were uh agreed upon
and released in a publication and these principles
are very important because they basically set
forward how you should be preparing your data
so that it is accessible uh and and usable by
researchers again across different domains uh
in order to verify your methodology and to build
upon uh your innovations uh then uh in uh more
recently in 2019 so you see again that that
interestingly enough uh this uh the non-human
genetic data uh sector is a little bit trailing
behind uh the human genetic data and i i see it's
interesting because personally as an ethicist
i could tell you there's less ethical challenge
probably in sharing non-human genetic data
than in sharing human genetic data nevertheless
uh it's only in 2019 that the public alliance for
genomic epidemiology was uh set forward uh and uh
it's basically an international alliance that
does similar work to what the global alliance does
uh but in the non-human uh genetic sector uh
and and finally of course uh i can't not mention
uh kobit 19 which has been a game changer in the
field of data sharing so uh of in january 2020 uh
coven 19 uh was declared by who to be a public
health emergency of international concern and
and as most of you know uh there's been uh first
of all genetics has really come to the spotlight
uh with uh coven 19 because we've been extremely
interested and had to study the variance of
covid their different effect uh and and how
they emerge and follow their outbreak their
development and evolution etc which was all done
through genetics and does the importance again
of not just collecting that information but
sharing it uh across region countries and
and making it available for the
community of researcher around the world
so now let's think a little bit about genetic
data and and think about what what is so
special about genetic data that we should
really uh have special procedure or be
careful when when sharing this data uh again
from an ethical legal social perspective so
first thing that we can say about genetic
information is that it is uniquely identifying
it can be used because it's uniquely
identifying we can use that information
also to discriminate between individual
and we can use it for profiling purpose
how can we use it to discriminate between
individual well genetic information of course uh
can be predictive of not only uh current health
we have diagno genetic diagnostic tests that exist
uh so so genes can be indicative uh of
a disease but most of the time they can
also be predictive of future health of course
most diseases genetic component as we all know
so that information is of course of interest
to other parties than just medical researchers
patient it's also interest to people like insurers
employers uh military uh organization etc uh
because of its predictive nature and and of course
uh this is an information genetic information
that we share with not just you know it's not
just uh unique to us but we share it with both our
close and distant relatives so sometime with whole
population group and and of course all of humanity
shares together in a substantial proportion of the
human genome so because of these characteristics
of genetic information what was proposed quite
early on there was this spirit of thought that
is called genetic exceptionalism and and what
was really behind this current of thought
was really saying because genetic information has
these unique characteristics it's very sensitive
and it should be protected by law uh at a higher
level we should have more stringent protection
over this type of information than over other
types of medical information or personal uh data
and and genetic exceptionalism we might
not hear the word as often today but it
is still quite relevant and and a lot of
people have this in mind when they talk
about protecting genetic information about
genetic privacy etc so it's still very influential
but there are strong arguments however that
have emerged against genetic exceptionalism
uh so uh for one thing uh it's been shown that
you know it was not just genetic biomarkers
that could be predictive uh of future health a
lot of non-genetic biomarkers can also predict
future health so for example we can talk about
cholesterol level we can talk about blood pressure
we can talk about a lot of other types of
biomarkers that are also predictive of future
health uh in fact i remember a year and a half
ago there was this famous article which presented
14 uh non-genetic biomarker they were mostly
chemical biomarkers that were predictive uh of
debt uh in in the fairly near future
i think it was over 10 and 20 years
so not something unique to genetic information
uh and also we've seen the emergence of a lot
of new uh disciplines linked with genetics such
as epigenetic pharmacogenetic microbiomics and
all those data share a lot of characteristics
with genetic information they're predictive they
can be unique identifier of an individual and by
unique identifier i mean really that it takes a
little bit of that type of information to really
uh identify an individual uniquely as in this
is you know the code that that belongs to this
particular individual of course it's not the same
thing as having the full identifying information
on that person but nevertheless it's going to
be very helpful to re-identify to find out the
identity of a person if you have another database
of course there's other types of data even that
share characteristics with genetic information
i've given a few examples on the slide lifestyle
environment demographic data etc so for all of
these reasons uh it makes one wonder should
we really have a specific focus on genetic and
and give it that extra amount of protection is it
really warranted and and furthermore it's been put
forward as well that we should be careful because
the more uh true or laws to our media we make
genetic information as being this sort of
pandora's box uh of of information that raise a
high level of risk and that's uh very stigmatizing
well we're creating this this sort of negative
image of what genetic information is and we're
participating and stigmatizing it more than than
we should really be so we have to be careful
that in over protecting it we might actually
make it more vulnerable so these were sort
of the arguments that have been put forward
against genetic exceptionalism and and still today
this sort of debate of should genetic information
uh be protected more than other health data or
or not uh is still ongoing to this day and it
has a big impact on public policy so let's check
our first sort of area that we will be discussing
uh so it's the area of data privacy so of course
the first hurdle that you will often hear when it
comes to time to share data is that well there are
legal and ethical requirements uh you know and and
institutional administrative requirements that
basically makes it very complicated or prevent
me as a researcher to share the data so the first
level uh privacy is the first level in a way of
hurdle that is often raised against data sharing
and of course privacy is important because privacy
is requisite of trust uh if you cannot trust the
system as a patient or as a research participant
you're not going to provide your information so it
does make sense to guarantee to people that will
be able to reasonably protect their information
and that's what privacy is all about uh privacy
of course applies to personal data which means
that it needs to belong to a person if i find
a blog spot on the street it's not personal data
because what it is is biological information but
i can't associate it uh to a person's identity
without going through an unreasonable amount
of uh challenge both from a technical level
legal level etc so because this blood spot uh
is sufficiently de-identified it's not associated
uh with a specific individual uh it's not personal
data according to and and then it's not protected
by privacy law uh similarly uh properly de-osted
and that's very important and was very important
in the context of uh kovid uh properly de-hosted
virus genome sequence does not constitute personal
data what do i mean thereby properly be hosted
well sometimes when you sequence uh the
covet virus that you've collected from
a human patient uh there is a bit of human
genetic data left mixed tangled with the viral
genome sequence so you have to de-host it
but once that is done you're talking about
the viral sequence you're talking about the
genome sequence of a virus so it's not human data
it's not personal data it's not identifying
therefore it can be shared quite easily because
it doesn't fall under the scope of privacy law
last point i want to make about privacy uh most
of the researcher that work internationally are
aware of the general data protection regulation
i have a feeling you'll probably hear more about
it in the context of other seminars of this series
it's just inconcernable you cannot go around
the general data protection regulation
it's a european regulation uh that carries extra
territorial weight and that it applies beyond the
european border and it's made to protect uh the
data privacy uh it's however a very contemporary
approach at protecting uh information it imposes
a lot of new responsibility over researchers
and so if you're going to be sharing your data
internationally especially if you're going to be
taking in european data you absolutely must know
about the requirement of gender of the the gdpr
and be able to meet those requirements
otherwise you will not be able to share
data with european colleagues uh how do we protect
privacy very quickly there are several ways
so again it's not something that is unfeasible
there are several approach to protecting your data
these are just a few key approaches to do that you
can de-identify your data so basically you remove
some of the metadata that is
associated with your genomic
data uh and up to a point where it's extreme
becomes extremely complicated to re-identify
it basically you have this genetic sequence but
you cannot uh link that genetic sequence with an
individual's identity the identity of a specific
individual without unreasonable effort so you
de-identify your genetic material by removing
for example the name of the person it belongs to
where they live their social insurance number
etc uh of course uh there are laws in the u.s
like ipa i know as some specific requirement for
the identification i'm not going to go there today
but they are a good starting place to see
what's needed to de-identify information
i.t security tools are all the
information technology programs
software tools that you can use to protect your
data they go from very simple things but that
you know everybody sort of know are needed such as
firewall all your normally all good university app
firewalls to protect the data of the university
uh coding encryption which has become increasingly
sophisticated password access etc beyond that
there are administrative measures you can take
and and are taken to protect data when
you're dealing with sensitive data you
use a tiered access system where basically people
have to agree to some specific contractual terms
if they want to see your data so that's what we
call the tiered access system that's where you
have those repository like dbgap that have access
committee that have specific requirement to give
you access to the data nowadays also uh we hear a
lot about data federation what's data federation
uh sometimes specific database are not willing to
share the data uh they want to keep the data in
the database and then what you can do is sometime
have a specific link between different database
and you can ask your query through a single portal
and obtain the information from that access portal
without viewing what's in the database you
only view the answer to your question in a
non-identifiable format so you're basically
protecting each local database but making
it possible to query them and to obtain a single
answer from these various databases and of course
uh we're at the day and age where everybody
should know that you can't protect privacy
uh completely you can only do your best you can
only do a reasonable effort and that must be made
clear to patient research participant etc uh what
basically you want to do is be transparent and say
here's what i can do and here's what i'm doing
to protect your data of course explain it in
terms that the late public can understand
and also it's nowadays uh one concept
that has become extremely important is that of
imputability somebody has to take responsibility
for protecting the information we need to
know who these people are very often now
you are required as an institution for example
if you're going to share data according to the
gdpr that i mentioned you need to have a data
privacy officer a person that's responsible
for privacy at your institution and
that's part of this idea of imputability
now why is it important to protect uh genetic
information well for for many reasons i mean it is
personal information of course and and everybody
know what what privacy breach can be conducive to
but the problem that's been particular to genetic
and that has been discussed a lot in the media
especially in the united states is the issue
of genetic discrimination it's a question i've
studied for many years uh and and one thing that's
interesting about genetic discrimination is that
the actual incidence of genetic discrimination
uh is is fairly uh a limited in terms of i mean
what we can do with genetic information right
now especially uh looking at the predictivity
of genetic information is limited uh to a
lot of monogenic highly penetrant disorder
of course we're now starting to move beyond that
uh we have we're even talking about polygenic risk
or but if you want to be able to uh predict which
almost certainty uh the development of a disease
in a way that this information could be available
and could be of interest to insurers employer etc
you're limited in in the number of diseases etc
that's why the incidence of genetic discrimination
has not been uh extremely widespread it's not
been seen all over uh the different use of genetic
that we make in the research and medical cons
context but nevertheless especially in the us
it's been a problem and and people are
quite concerned about genetic discrimination
they need to be reassured they need to know
that their genetic information uh is protected
and and uh one word maybe about the
map that you can see on this slide
is just to give you a sense of uh the studies
that have been done on genetic discrimination
on the topic of life insurance and
what it shows you is that we know
very little still about the phenomenon of genetic
discrimination and in order to address it and to
develop laws uh that will be efficient against
genetic discrimination there's a need to study it
uh in much more details because our laws are not
that effective yet at countering these problems
uh and and we're also we also have to
think nowadays about uh stigmatization
and discrimination at the level of population
this is going to become one key issue in genetic
because we want to have a data set that
are more diverse we want to represent
minority group of the population in our studies so
that they can benefit from research but in doing
that this the the effect is that there might
be some use of this information to stigmatize
or discriminate these populations so we have to
be very careful as we're proceeding in this good
direction of including more minority group in the
research and for those interested in this please
contact me at the genetic discrimination
observatory what we do is really attempt to
tackle this genetic discrimination issue the way
that i believe it should be done which is at the
international level uh because genetic information
is now shared across national border we cannot
have this uh local view of genetic discrimination
mind you it's important to be active at the local
and national level but we also need to add this
larger perspective on it of how can we adopt again
rules that are coherent at the international
level to prevent genetic discrimination
i spoke about the importance of diversity uh
it's it's another of these big questions now
uh in in data sharing so how can we make sure
that we're not sharing only data on white
people of european ancestry how can we be more
inclusive in the data types that we take on uh
and and use so we first of all have to understand
why some of these uh minority groups are reluctant
to participate and one of the first reason is what
we call intersectionality which is very often uh
it's the same group that are already victimized
uh based on racial discrimination based on poverty
on access to health care etc that are the most
at risk of again being victimized by let's say
genetic discrimination it always fall on the same
group which is why you're sort of reluctant when
you talk to them about participating in genetic
research so one of the first thing that should be
realized is this this problem of intersectionality
and how can we address it uh to make uh these
population uh that have been uh victimized and
more marginalized by society how can we make them
confident that that with genetic research this is
going to be different and lead to benefit for them
uh considering them and including them in our data
as i said it's an ethical and medical imperative
any scientists will tell you in genetics that if
you only use data from a white european population
well you're only going to get robust genetic
result for those population and so your result
will only have limited application and will not
benefit a lot large population group within even
a single country so how do you do this how
can you make sure you have these groups you
have to start early if you want to include these
minority population group you have to engage them
early to know what their expectations are are
there specific terms of engagement for them to
participate that are important for them you need
to build the trust that has been eroded over the
years of abuse so the earlier you can start
engaging them in the process the better it is
and collecting data is not sufficient we
have some type database that actually took it
upon himself to collect this data but because
the data is still in smaller quantity then
the data of european population the data
basically lay dormant and database and it's not
used by researchers uh the there's a duty
for scientific researcher to use this data
it's really important uh and so they should almost
justify not using it if they're not going to use
all the data from the different population data
that are in a database so again some tips to to
increase the participation of minority population
think about whether specific uh consent modalities
uh would be useful think about maybe how to
address the concern that that there might be
data misuse or genetic discrimination uh is is a
law needed or some sort of regulation to give them
more protection etc uh also self-governance is
becoming extremely important for those community
so they want to have some seen what is
done in the data they want to be involved
uh they want to benefit from the research
capacity building is important equitable
access to drugs that may be developed from the
research might be a consideration and and finally
uh it's it's it's you need to from the get-go uh
build this relationship and start this engagement
but also as regulator i think it's critically
important that strong metrics are developed
to then be able to assess uh how researchers have
performed on on this particular task of including
more diverse uh population uh in in their data
set and and use this data in their research so
metrics are key uh i've put one article that's
proposing interesting metrics and interesting
metrics approach in the context of coven 19 so you
may want to have a look at that particular article
another key area if you're thinking of sharing
data is the area of attribution and reward it's
often sometimes we don't think about it we sort
of assume that the people who produce the data
that create the database that they will share
their data uh they will not automatically share
their data i i used to have uh a slide uh those of
you that are familiar with the lord of the rings
uh know the creature golem and i i often would
compare a researcher's relationship to their data
with that of gollum in the ring in that it is it
is their treasure the data is the treasure of the
researcher so how do you get them to share this
treasure well you get you get them to do that by
giving them something that they would like to have
and and these are some suggestion of what should
be given to researcher of course co-authorship
might be warranted in some cases sometime it
might just be more of an acknowledgement
there might be collaboration requirements
the problem right now with that is that
those rules vary by discipline by country
they're not as well aligned at the international
level and for example between the human genetics
and the public health genetics branch uh
they're very different and so when you want
these branches to collaborate it's going to make
things more complicated because they're going to
have different expectations additional funding of
course funders need to contribute to data sharing
it's not going to happen without a cost and so
somebody asked checkout researchers with the cost
of data sharing uh there's been other mechanisms
sometimes to anchorage researcher that i like a
bit less uh embargo is an example where basically
we're going to say to a researcher it's it's
almost like a patent where you say to a researcher
well you can share your data and uh will will
embargo it meaning nobody's going to use it people
are going to be able to view it but it's going to
take a couple of years before they can actually
do something with it so that you have a head start
it becomes problematic especially if the embargo
is for a substantially long period of time
another one that i'm not a fan on
is is intellectual property right
uh i think they need especially if you're uh
upstream in the research process and genetic
uh i would not recommend the use of ip
right i think that you know you want to
make it clear actually that uh you shouldn't
be patenting anything like raw genomic data
first of all in most patent system across the
world uh patenting raw genomic data is is not
something that's possible but it's also really
not conducive to good collaborative science
so beyond all of these elements that i just
mentioned now there are a lot of administrative
burden that make data sharing complicated and
so this is for example you know it's almost like
a checklist if a researcher's car because very
often i have colleagues at the university that are
starting and it's sort of the first time that they
are into a big uh genetic project and they come to
me and they say well what do i need to do to share
my data what do i need to think of so these are
all the administrative steps that will likely have
to happen for you uh to be able to share your data
uh you're gonna have to have a consent form
where you're gonna recruit research participant
that's gonna be fairly broad meaning
that it's gonna allow you to do
many things with the data uh it's not gonna be uh
permitting research on a really specific disease
no it's gonna be i want to use my the data i'm
collecting from you uh in all kinds of medical
research it's gonna permit to you to share
your data internationally all these things
have to be included in the in the consent so
you need to really tailor your informed consent
very carefully as you start recruiting participant
then also before you get started you're going to
need a governance model a governance framework
for your database and a data access model as in
what are the requirement that people are going
to have to meet in order to access my data
finally well you're going to also have to
think about what are the specific privacy
requirement and setting that my database will have
so uh is the data that is going to be stored in my
database is it going to be coded genetic data so
basically i don't have any direct identifiers such
as a name uh or a social insurance number but i
may have indirect identifier and there is a code
that links uh my genetic information uh with
the name and somebody is able to let's say
uh link the genetic information with the medical
file of the participant so we're talking coded
data here that can be how you're going to work in
your database or it could be anonymized data where
you decide that you're not going to no longer
need the personal information and so you strip it
permanently you're talking more about anonymized
data and about the identified data set if you
do that so these are some of the privacy setting
and all of the other things that we talked about
uh when we covered the question of uh privacy then
we're gonna have to think about ethics approval r
is the data that's in my database first of all
am i needing an ethics approval to collect it
from participant do i need to have their
consent as we've mentioned do i need a tax
approval but also furthermore will researchers
that want to have access to my database
need to have an ethics approval in order to
access my data so you have to think about
this in both direction if you're providing data
access you also have to set up your data access
comedy if you're going to be giving access to
sensitive data and prepare data access agreement
of course there's way to circumvent some of
these burdens so you may want to use dbgap as a
repository for your data in that case uh they have
their own data access committee of course you will
still stipulate the access conditions so what's
in the access agreement to some extent but they
will provide the infrastructure the committee
etc so some of these steps can be circumvented
and finally of course there's a whole technical
steps that is required to prepare the data uh
for the user and and the download time so all of
these things that also uh need to be considered
so in concluding my presentation before we open it
to question i would say that that these are some
these are some steps that i would say are part
of a path forward that will make life easier
for people that want to share data so early
preparedness is key uh nowadays if you're going
to do large-scale genetic research don't think
you're going to do much in the first years because
you're not anybody that's been in the business
will tell you uh you're gonna take about a year
or more two years some time to just engage the
population group that you want to recruit and
to develop uh your your governance framework for
your data so this is part of the cost of you know
sharing data that you have to keep in mind
early engagement with vulnerable population
uh and and also you need to really uh
think uh again from a really perspective uh
way of okay what are the risks that my data incur
from the start what's the risk what could be some
of the possible worst event how can i prevent them
and how can i convey to my participant the level
of privacy that i'll be able to provide to the
data damn i think that a really important step
and and as for the entire research community
uh is to limit the number of data repository
uh you know there there is some time uh you know
this this feeling of again it's my data therefore
you know i want my own representative because
i want to be in control uh there's there's that
desire to even though you know and you have no
choice but to share your data to want to retain
control of the data therefore to think well i'll
have my own repository this way i can really
control things uh it's it's it's really not a good
idea unless you have a strong reason to do that
other than just controlling the data otherwise i
would say simply use you know a larger repository
make sure that the condition that that of access
respond to your particular need but but please
don't multiply repository it just makes data
access more complicated and more procedural
across the board for everybody and try to keep
the administrative step to access data to district
minimum you don't always need a complex data
access agreement followed by a material transfer
agreement followed by piecemeal negotiation
process you can very often you know have this done
in a very limited amount of step via a very simple
agreement and this is what people should strive to
do and and finally as i said this is an ecosystem
we're not just a researcher of responsibilities
but all the different parts of the ecosystem need
to be involved and funding agency especially need
to provide the financial cost that is required
to share data for researchers and i i want to
also and i think this is going to be really
important for researchers working in this field
these are some of the key uh good practices
that i would really direct you to uh that
could be extremely useful if you want to develop
a repository and and have a governance framework
that's going to be strong from a fair data
access and international data access perspective
here are some of the key uh documents and
guidelines that really you would need to
follow and to take into account and i'll be happy
to speak more specifically to some of these if
there are questions and i want to thank you very
much for listening be happy to answer a question
as you can see that my dogs and cats were
there doing the oversight uh while i was
present preparing my presentation so i
i want to acknowledge their help as well
and and of course all the funders uh thank you
very much and and we can open it uh to questions
thank you so much john i really appreciate your
comments that my first question is do you have to
offer your dogs and your cats co-authorships
on anything that uh you produce i i i think
that again you know you you need to think about
enticement and now i can get them to cooperate and
i think food's more appropriate for today very
food motivated you know you brought up in all
seriousness you've got several different elements
and i i liked how you really kind of uh touched on
the tension that exists between openness of data
and security and the research potential that that
data has that kind of that that triad of push-pull
relationships with exit that exists on that
i i'm very curious to to get your sense of like
what is it that keeps people from really wanting
to share their data sometimes people hide behind
security and say oh i couldn't do it and my irb
will never let me do it but on the other hand
that sort of can be kind of perceived sometimes
as a cop-out are there other reasons why people
might not want to share their data or hide behind
you know sort of i don't know not necessarily the
the the best reasons to to share their data right
so today we we've addressed the real
hurdles of course uh there are very often
other reason and and and with kovitz some of these
reasons have become quite apparent so uh i would
i will only name two for example uh i think a lot
of time when when you talk about data sharing with
with a commercial enterprise with pharmaceutical
company or biotech small biotech startup
uh well they're worried about sharing their data
because for them it's it's an asset and and uh
you know they have to make a profit it's not
like a publicly funded researcher right where
you can have the argument of well you're funded
by the public and your research should directly
benefit the public so in those cases uh very
often but but to be fair even some publicly
funded researchers will want to keep their data
secret uh to to have a commercial advantage
or what they perceive to be a commercial advantage
because they're afraid that if they don't share
they'll be scooped another interesting phenomenon
that we've seen during covet is uh really public
health sometimes being public health agencies
uh not always being willing to share their data
with the research community and interestingly one
of the key reason why they don't like to do that
was a fear that their data was going to be
misrepresented by researcher that you know it
could be used to show that they had done mistake
in their own work or uh to give an image that
would be for example more alarmist uh than than
what the situation was really in a given state
or province and so they they sort of felt that it
was sort of written mandate sometimes to prevent
that sharing in order to to protect these i would
say personal interest and and when i say that i'm
mostly building from my experience in canada where
i was quite involved in data sharing for research
uh but i i don't know you can you can tell me
if that also resonates within what uh with what
happened in the u.s oh yeah absolutely lots of
people have um a lot of reasons they'll say well
i don't have the staff to do that i don't have the
funds to support it um some but even uh just in my
own experience i've experienced where people will
say well my experiment is too complicated for me
to explain it to you so i'm not going to share my
data and if you point out to people that perhaps
that doesn't meet the definition of science then
uh they they they don't tend to like that so much
um but on the other hand there are these sort of
enticements as you referred to earlier things like
co-authorships or certainly acknowledgements or
collaborations on grants or or you know some some
uh you know funding related activities you know at
what point do some of these relationships become
sort of a quid pro quo kind of you know cost of
doing business i want to use this data and now
i have to give these people an acknowledgement or
a co-authorship which i hadn't intended to do but
now i have to do it it some people see that as a
negative and so it actually means that they don't
use certain repositories that they might otherwise
want to take advantage of do you find that as well
uh yes i mean i i i it happens i think the key
here is is as you say it's a key pro code so
you really need to uh both parties need
to find an advantage there and and so
one of the problem right now as i mentioned is
those rules are not harmonized and in some field
those rules are extremely restrictive such as you
cannot use my data uh if you don't you know if if
i don't agree with what you're proposing to do
i want to see a plan i want you to then share
your result with me so that i can use your result
myself uh i so so plenty of conditions that that
can make it quite complicated you're not gonna
patent uh your result ever uh things like that
so i think that that the key here is
really working hard on this harmonization
of uh acknowledgement and and attribution rules
and and first of all start within broad sectors
uh and then really even across sectors because
i would say that that very often there's no real
strong justification why would for example in in
in one sector uh somebody that produces data would
need to be a co-author on a publication in order
to share his or her data while in another sector
uh simply give them a thank you or acknowledging
the repository uh through a citation format
is is sufficient uh you know it's we we we should
be agreeing on whether we're we're okay with
citation and and acknowledgement which i think
is is enough in most cases or whether sometimes
co-authorship is is really warranted and i would
say that only where there's a real collaboration
and and the substantial role of the data
producer in the final paper uh would would this
co-authorship really be warranted so with regard
to collaboration what can early career researchers
do to get involved with efforts like your own to
help improve the data sharing policy and practice
well i think i think for for the next few
years uh just documenting the experience
of those early researchers is going to
be key because uh one of the strongest
argument against data sharing is that
it has a really important adverse impact
on early career researchers and on people who
have smaller genetic project because mainly they
they risk being scooped and and also the cost is
just too heavy for them to bear so i think it's
really important for them to speak out make sure
that the challenges they meet and data sharing
uh is is is well reflected and is heard by spot by
research funders so that we can adopt you know we
can adapt the rules of data sharing uh for them
uh to be fair to to those new players and those
important player if we wanted to happen across the
board we really have to have a system that's going
to have that built-in flexibility where again
data sharing is going to be attractive by everyone
for everyone in the ecosystem and right now i
don't think it is as attractive as it should be
uh for for newer researchers and and small scale
researcher who have to learn all those rules and
think about all those processes that they need to
do if they ever want to get into big data and ai
yann thank you so much for sharing your your
your thoughts with us and very thought-provoking
about how we can improve upon data sharing how we
can do just better what that means for our science
uh respectively and what it means internationally
i that this is so absolutely vital i was really
felt that that was a really strong statement
we have to do this internationally because
different countries have different rules
we need to communicate with each other
science knows doesn't know you know political
boundaries or geographic boundaries we we
really need to improve things across
the the planet if we're going to uh be
successful scientifically moving into the
deeper into the 21st century and beyond so
thank you so much for sharing your thoughts
with us uh this has been really helpful and